qu'il n'est pas très difficile de gagner quelqu'un à sa cause
pour qu'il trahisse d'autres personnes.
Même certains des dissidents principaux en Allemagne de l'Est
coopéraient avec la Stasi,
comme par exemple Ibrahim Böhme.
En 1989, il fut le leader de la révolution pacifique,
et il devint presque le premier Premier Ministre librement élu de RDA
avant que l'on découvre qu'il était un indicateur.
Le réseau d'espions était vraiment large.
Dans presque chaque institution,
même dans les églises ou en Allemagne de l'Ouest,
il y en avait beaucoup.
Je me souviens avoir dit à un officier supérieur de la Stasi,
« Si vous m'aviez envoyé un indicateur,
je l'aurais sûrement reconnu. »
Sa réponse fut :
« Nous n'avons envoyé personne.
Nous avons pris ceux qui étaient autour de vous. »
Et de fait, deux de mes meilleurs amis
renseignaient la Stasi à mon sujet.
Les indics étaient très proches, et pas que dans mon cas.
Par exemple, Vera Lengsfeld, une autre dissidente majeure,
dans son cas c'était son mari qui l'espionnait.
Un écrivain célèbre fut trahi par son frère.
Ça me rappelle le roman « 1984 » de George Orwell,
ou la seule personne apparemment digne de confiance
est un indicateur.
Mais pourquoi la Stasi collectait-elle toute ces informations
dans ses archives ?
L'objectif principal était de contrôler la société.
Dans presque chaque discours, le ministre de la Stasi
ordonnait de découvrir qui était qui,
ce qui signifiait qui pensait quoi.
Il ne voulait pas attendre que quelqu'un
tente d'agir contre le régime.
Il voulait savoir à l'avance
ce que les gens pensaient et préparaient.
Les Allemands de l'Est savait, bien sûr,
qu'ils étaient entourés d'indicateurs,
dans un régime totalitaire créant la méfiance
et un état de peur généralisée,
les outils les plus importants pour opprimer la population
dans toute dictature.
C'est pourquoi peu d'Allemands de l'Est ont essayé
de lutter contre le régime communiste.
S'ils le faisaient, la Stasi utilisait souvent une méthode
qui était vraiment diabolique.
On l'appelait Zersetzung,
et c'est décrit dans un autre livret d'instructions.
Le mot est difficile à traduire, parce qu'il signifie
à l'origine « biodégradation ».
Mais en faite, c'est une description assez pertinente.
Le but était de détruire secrètement
la confiance que les gens avaient en eux-mêmes,
par exemple en salissant leur réputation,
en organisant des échecs professionnels,
et en détruisant leurs relations personnelles.
Là-dessus, l'Allemagne de l'Est était une dictature très moderne.
La Stasi n'essayait pas d'arrêter chaque dissident.
Elle préférait les paralyser,
et elle le pouvait
parce qu'elle avait accès à toutes ces informations personnelles
et à toutes ces institutions.
On n'emprisonner quelqu'un
qu'en dernier recours.
Pour ça, la Stasi possédait 17 centres de détention provisoire,
un dans chaque district.
Ici, la Stasi développait aussi
des méthodes de détention assez modernes.
En général, l'officier qui interrogeait
ne torturait pas le prisonnier.
Au lieu de ça, il utilisait un système sophistiqué
de pression psychologique
dans lequel une stricte isolation était essentielle.
Presque aucun prisonnier ne résistait
sans donner un témoignage.
Si vous en avez l'occasion,
visitez l'ancienne prison de la Stasi à Berlin
et suivez une visite guidée avec un ancien prisonnier politique
qui vous expliquera comment tout ça fonctionnait.
Il faut encore répondre à une question :
si la Stasi était si bien organisée,
pourquoi le régime communiste s'est-il effondré ?
Premièrement, en 1989, les dirigeants d'Allemagne de l'Est
ne savaient pas quoi faire contre
les manifestations toujours plus nombreuses de la population.
Ils étaient particulièrement déstabilisés
parce que dans le pays père du socialisme,
l'Union soviétique,
une politique plus libérale se mettait en place.
De surcroît, le régime dépendait
des prêts en provenance de l'Ouest.
C'est pour ça qu'aucun ordre d'écraser le soulèvement
ne fut donné à la Stasi.
Deuxièmement, dans l'idéologie communiste,
il n'y a pas de place pour la critique.
Au lieu de ça, les dirigeants s'accrochèrent à l'idée
que le socialisme est un système parfait,
et la Stasi devait le confirmer, bien sûr.
La conséquence,
c'est qu'en dépit de toute l'information,
le régime ne pouvait pas analyser ses véritables problèmes,
et ne pouvait donc pas les résoudre.
En définitive, la Stasi est morte
à cause des structures
qu'elle était en charge de protéger.
La fin de la Stasi
fut quelque chose de tragique,
parce que ses officiers
ne furent occupés, pendant la révolution pacifique,
qu'à une seule chose :
détruire les documents
qu'ils avaient produits pendant des décennies.
Heureusement,
ils ont été stoppés par des militants des droits de l'homme.
C'est pour ça que nous pouvons utiliser ces fichiers aujourd'hui
pour mieux comprendre
comment fonctionne un État de surveillance.
Merci.
[Applaudissements]
Bruno Giussani : Merci. Merci beaucoup.
Hubertus, je voudrais vous poser quelques questions
parce que j'ai ici le « Spiegel » de la semaine dernière.
Mein Nachbar NSA. Mon voisin, la NSA.
Et vous venez de me parler de mon voisin,
les espions et les indics d'Allemagne de l'Est.
Y-a-t-il un lien direct entre ces deux histoires
ou non ?
Comment réagissez-vous
comme historien
quand vous voyez ça ?
HK : je crois qu'il y a
plusieurs aspects à considérer.
D'abord, je pense qu'il y a une différence
quant à la raison pour laquelle vous collectez ces données.
Le faites-vous pour protéger votre population
contre des attaques terroristes,
ou le faites-vous pour opprimer la population ?
Ça fait une différence fondamentale.
Mais d'un autre côté,
dans une démocratie aussi, on peut abuser de ces outils,
et nous devons vraiment être vigilants
pour pouvoir l'empêcher,
et vérifier que les services de renseignement
respectent les règles en place.
Troisième point, sans doute,
nous devons vraiment être heureux de vivre en démocratie,
parce que vous pouvez être sûrs que la Russie et la Chine
font la même chose,
mais personne n'en parle
parce que personne n'en serait capable.
[Applaudissements]
BG : Quand l'histoire est sortie,
en juillet l'année dernière,
vous avez porté plainte
auprès d'un tribunal allemand. Pourquoi ?
HK : Oui, je l'ai fait à cause du second point que j'ai mentionné,
parce qu'en démocratie en particulier
les règles sont là pour tout le monde.
Elles sont là pour tous, donc ce n'est pas normal
qu'une institution ne respecte pas ces règles.
Dans le Code criminel allemand, il est écrit
qu'il est interdit de mettre quelqu'un
sur écoute sans l'autorisation du juge.
Heureusement, c'est écrit dans le Code criminel allemand,
donc si ce n'est pas respecté, je pense
qu'une enquête est nécessaire,
et il a fallu beaucoup de temps pour que
le procureur allemand commence cette enquête
et il ne l'a ouverte que dans le cas d'Angela Merkel,
et pas pour toutes les autres personnes qui vivent en Allemagne.
BG : Ça ne me surprend pas à cause —
[Applaudissements] —
à cause de l'histoire que vous avez racontée.
Vu de l'extérieur, je vis hors d'Allemagne,
et je pensais
que les Allemands réagiraient
bien plus violemment, immédiatement.
Alors que la réaction
n'est réellement venue
que quand on a révélé
que la chancelière Merkel
était sur écoute. Pourquoi ?
HK : Je vois ça comme un bon signe,
parce que les gens se sentent en sécurité dans cette démocratie.
Ils n'ont pas peur d'être arrêtés,
et quand vous quitterez ce hall après la conférence,
vous n'aurez pas à craindre que la police secrète
n'attende dehors pour vous arrêter.
Donc je pense
que c'est un signe positif.
Les gens n'ont pas peur.
Mais bien sûr, les institutions
ont le devoir de stopper les actions illégales
en Allemagne et partout où elles sont commises.
BG : Une question personnelle, et c'est la dernière.
Il y a un débat en Allemagne pour savoir s'il faut
donner l'asile à Edward Snowden.
Seriez-vous pour ou contre ?
HK : C'est une question difficile,
mais si vous me la posez,
et si je réponds franchement,
je lui donnerais l'asile,
parce je pense que ce qu'il a fait
était vraiment courageux
et il a détruit sa vie entière,
sa famille, et tout le reste.
Donc je pense que pour ces gens, nous devrions faire quelque chose,
surtout si vous regardez l'histoire allemande,
où tant de gens durent s'échapper
et demandèrent l'asile à l'étranger,
et ne l'obtinrent pas,
donc ce serait un signe positif de lui donner l'asile.
[Applaudissements]
BG : Hubertus, merci beaucoup.